[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans sens public
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité nous sommes le lundi 13
novembre et nous sommes ensemble pour 1
heure et dei de débat et de décryptage
une marche et après que restera-t-il du
12 novembre après la mobilisation contre
l'antisémitisme réussi hier des
questions se pose comment traduire en
acte ce sursau citoyen afin de faire
baisser la haine antijuif et puis étons
en train d'assister à une recomposition
politique nous en débattrons avec mes
invités dans la première partie de cette
émission dans la seconde partie de cette
émission nous nous consacrerons à la
sjordanie l'autre territoire l'autre
impasse du conflit israélo-palestinien
colonisé depuis 50 ans au mépris du Doig
international cet enclave morcelé
connaît un regain de tension depuis les
attaques terroristes du Hamas le 7
octobre alors quelle est la réalité de
cette guerre sourde qui ne dit pas son
nom nous ferons le point avec nos
experts mais tout de suite place à notre
premier débat ils étaient 182000 hier à
travers la France à défilé dans une
grande dignité autour d'un mot d'ordre
très simple pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme retour sur une
mobilisation inédite avec Mathias SZ
pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme derrière ce mot d'ordre
une foule calme et compacte s'était
lancé de l'Esplanade des Invalides hier
après-midi en tête de cortège ancien
président Premier ministre mais surtout
les présidents de l'Assemblée nationale
et du sén à l'initiative de cette marche
une marche civique dont l'ambition était
de dépasser l'éclivage politique dans la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme c'est
extrêmement réjouissant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui en France nous sommes
capables de nous rassembler aussi
rapidement faud pas simplement que ça
soit une marche faut qu'une marche
conduise à une démarche et cette
démarche doit nous conduire à plus que
jamais les valeurs de la République tous
les partis hormis la France insoumise
sont
une nécessité pour l'ancien Premier
ministre Édouard
Philippe en France on sait ce que c'est
que l'antisémitisme on a une vieille
histoire dans d'antisémitisme on a un
vieux démon qui nous travaille il ne
révèle jamais le meilleur de la France
il conduit toujours dans le mur donc que
les autorités publiqu disent
solennellement ça n'est pas la France
que nous voulons nous connaissons le
danger de l'antisémiste nous n'en
voulons pas c'était quelque chose d'Ant
mais le cortège parisien de plus de
100000 manifestants a connu quelques
tension
casse-toi pas de toi éic Zemour chef de
fil de reconquête mais surtout Marine Le
Pen entourée d'une vingtaine de
parlementaires sont là parmi les absents
remarqués Emmanuel Macron le président
n'a pas souhaité participer à la
polémique selon son entourage un coup
manqué pour Robert Ménard il dit il faut
l'unité des Français il faut un message
d'humanité et c'était quoi hier c'était
quoi hier c'était pas un message d'unité
c'était pas un un message d'humanité
bien sûr que sa place était là mais je
pense qu'il a commis une erreur en
réponse ce lundi le président de la
République a reçu les représentants des
principaux cultes présents en France à
l'Élysée que restera-t-il de la Marche
pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme on en parle ce soir avec
mes invités bonsoir Jean garig bonsoir
vous êtes historien président du Comité
d'histoire parlementaire à vos côté
adéaï zulfiarpassic bonsoir vous êtes
directrice générale de BVA enseignante à
sciencep j'accueille aussi clloé Ridel
vous êtes porte-parole du Parti
socialiste bonsoir et puis notre
éditorialiste tranui qui m'accompagnera
tout au long de cette émission bonsoir
Tam d'abord un mot pour qualifier cette
marche d'IER en commençant avec vous
l'historien Jean garig est-ce que c'est
une marche historique tout est
historique et par définition un
historien va considérer un événement
historique mais 10 ans après ou 20 ans
après c'est l'avenir qui nous dira si
c'était historique il y a quand même une
dimension exceptionnelle parce que
c'était une véritablement une une marche
d'abord pour célébrer des valeurs des
valeurs qui sont celles de de la
République finalement c'est pas si
fréquent on est habitué à des
manifestations qui portent sur des
sujets sociaux culturels politiques là
il y avait quelque chose de de de
particulier et puis il y avait aussi le
fait pour moi c'est assez important ce
que cette cette marche était organisé
par deux représentants de nos
institutions républicaines et qui plus
est des institutions parlementaire ce
que ce ce qui me tient à cœur et donc
c'était dans cette dans cette idée
d'avoir au fond des citoyens qui se
réunissent c'était pas des partis
politiques c'était deux institutions qui
rassemblent les citoyens au service
d'une d'une cause qui est évidente qui
est la défense des principes
républicains en l'occurrence focalisé
sur sur l'antisémitisme mais ça pouvait
être ça aurait pu être tout autre chose
donc il y a quelque chose d'exceptionnel
mais l'histoire nous nous dira si
c'était historique s'il y a quelque
chose qui suit comme le disait Gérard
Larcher on passe de la marche à la
démarche et s'il y a pas une démarche
derrière quelque chose de fort je suis
pas sûr qu'on gardera le souvenir de
cette manifestation alors on va en
débattre tout au long de cette émission
cl Ridel céit une marche ou une
manifestation c'est quoi la différence
c'était une marche et une manifestation
c'est une marche très digne j'ai trouvé
j'y étais hier avec le Parti socialiste
mais aussi avec les écologistes avec les
communistes il y avait beaucoup de monde
plus de 105000 personnes à Paris moins
un peu moins de 200000 en France et
c'était un moment important que cette
marche dans une situation qui est
gravissime en France euh parce que on
connaît une multiplication des actes
antisémites plusis de plus de 1200
depuis le 7 octobre avec un amalgam
insupportable qui est fait entre les
crimes que peut connaître que peut
commettre l'armée d'Israël à Gaza et les
Juifs de France eu et donc cet
emballement de haine à l'égard à l'égard
à l'égard des Juifs et nous nous avons
voulu dire et c'est important c'était
important que de le dire à la marche
d'hier nous sommes au côté des juifs et
des Juifs de France ils ne sont pas
seuls et nous ne les laissons pas seuls
face à la haine et ça je pense que
c'était un message que ils avaient
besoin d'entendre parce que nombreux
sont ceux qui depuis 3 semaines ne
dorment pas sont extrêmement haqués ont
peur pour leur vie hein c'est une jeune
femme juif qui a été poirnièd à Lyon
c'est des octagénaires dans le 20e
arrondissement juif qui se sont fait
brûler leurs portes parce qu'il y avait
une Musa à leur à leur porte donc c'est
important de se réunir
hier pour dire vous touchez au cheveux
d'un juif vous touchez à tous les
Français et donc pas touche et nous
sommes sommes à leur côté vous parlez de
ce sentiment de peur d'isolement je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage de
Bernard Lonchamp membre du bureau de la
Licra du barrain qui organisait la
marche à Strasbourg à laquelle 5000
personnes ont participé hier c'est
important et c'est réconfortant qu'on
soit pas seul parce que nous on est une
association avec quelques centaines
d'adhérents mais qui est d'autres
personnes qui a répondu à notre appel il
faut marquer le coup il faut
l'antisémitisme et le racisme aussi
parce que les deux vont sont ensemble
évidemment de certaine façon sont des
véritables dangers actuellement pour
notre République et pour notre pays ad
zulfarp est-ce que 182000 c'est beaucoup
est-ce que c'est une marche populaire au
sens est-ce que su par l'opinion alors
euh il y a deux questions dans votre
dans votre question est-ce que c'est
beaucoup en valeur absolue je je saurais
pas dire j'ai j'ai pas de référents
enfin on a des référents mais qui sont
d'autre nature mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que c'est beaucoup il y a
deux éléments qui sont notables par
rapport à à cela le premier vos invités
prè on dit avant moi c'était une marche
qui était qui s'est bien passé qui s'est
passé dans dans une atmosphère sereine
sans heure et c'est important de le
souligner dans le contexte actuel qui en
dehors même de ce que évoqué cl Ridel
est extrêmement anxiogène est un
contexte global social sociétal très
sombre on le voit dans les enquête
d'opinion les gens les gens sont
inquiets les gens ont peur pour leur
avenir celui de leurs enfants pour le
pays un espèce de climatis la rentré un
climat global avec les questions
climatiques et cetera qui a été accru
depuis les attaques du 7 octobre et
d'ailleurs on voit que la hiérarchie des
préoccupations des Français a été
complètement boulversé les questions
sociales sont passées au second plan
derre derrière les questions
sécuritaires d'immigration et cetera et
don dans un climat où le pays est tendu
je trouve remarquable que la marche soit
bien passée et par ailleurs par rapport
à votre question de est-ce qu'il y a un
soutien il y a eu quelques enquêtes qui
ont été réalisé juste avant la marche
qui montrait qu'une large majorité de
Français au moins 7/ 10 étit favorable à
cette marche donc oui il y a il y a un
mouvement alors qui ne concerne pas tous
les Français mais il y a quand même un
mouvement global d'appui à cette marche
Jean garig est-ce que c'était une marche
de vieux on n pas vu beaucoup de jeunes
hier dans alors c'était pas une marche
de jeunes ça c'est une une certitude
mais moi j'ai pas trouvé que c'était une
marche de boomer il y avait quand même
beaucoup de gens entre 30 et 50 ans
c'était pas uniquement ces ces seiors
que qui aujourd'hui ont on mauvaise
presse qu'on qu'on voir disparaître et
qui incarnerait une forme de
conservatisme macronien non c'était
beaucoup plus mêlé que que ça évidemment
il manquait une forte représentation des
des jeunes il y a beaucoup
d'explications à ça ne serait-ce que
parce que pour toute une partie de la
connaiss les étudiants que que je
connais un peu je je sais que la cause
palestinienne leur tient à cœur et que
beaucoup ont à tort identifier cette
manifestation comme une forme de
manifestation de soutien à la politique
israélienne ce que ça n'était pas du
tout il y a pas eu un slogan il y avait
pas une pas une affiche pas un drapeau
pas et et et une manifestation qui s'est
passée vraiment dans dans le dans le
calme la sérénité quoi mais je je pense
que il doit y avoir ce préjugé
défavorable pour beaucoup de jeunes ce à
quoi il faut ajouter aussi leur leur
désintérêt pour l'engagement politique
peut-être qu'ils sont un peu plus loin
aussi que que ça et il y a un troisième
élément qui un élément historique c'est
que pour une génération la génération
des des jeunes d'aujourd'hui ben les
événements qui ont marqué notre histoire
ils sont tragiquement notre histoire
s'éloigne un peu et qui a donc tout un
effort pédagogique alors les enseignants
les universitaires comme moi on essaie
de le faire en permanence de le rappeler
mais je pense que c'est c'est pas mal
quand même de revenir là-dessus et de
montrer que l'antisémitisme il a une
histoire dans notre pays et que cette
histoire là elle a beaucoup marqué et
beaucoup fait de mal à notre démocratie
et donc c'est c'était important aussi de
de le rappeler et c'est dommage qu'il a
pas eu suffisamment de jeune et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut continuer
alors on rappelle le contexte de cette
marche vous y faisiez allusion cllo
Ridel
1247 signalement d'actes antisémite
depuis le 7 octobre je dis signalement
parce que c'est pas le nombre total
d'actes antisémite bien évidemment ce
sont des signalements on peut imaginer
qu'il y en a plus soit c'est
l'équivalent en gros de trois fois
l'année 2022 adelaïd zulfiarpassic
est-ce que les Français sont plus
antisémites qu'avant qu'il y a 20 ans
alors j'allais dire ça dépend de ce
qui'est le avant mais effectivement par
rapport à y a 20 ans en fait il y a il y
a un outil qui est très puissant pour
suivre ces sujets là c'est l'outil mis
en place par la com par de 3 CNCDH ou
CNCDH je vous ai pu le prer c'est la
commission nationale pardon cons des
droits de l'homme qui qui a mis en place
un baromètre qui a effectivement au
moins 20 ans d'existance et qui revient
sur ces questions là et on voit que de
façon longitudinale globalement quand
même il y a un indice de tolérance qui
qui est mesuré par par le rapport annuel
de la CNCDH qui tend à montrer une lente
progression de la tolérance et une
baisse de l'antisémitisme pour autant et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que ce que préconise
la CNCDH dans son rapport de il faut
rester extrêmement vigilant sur ces
sujets-l et dans le dernier rapport de
la CNCDH que j'ai consulté avant de
venir il note que malgré l'émergence
d'un nouvel antisémitisme qui
s'appuiererait sur un antisionisme
amalgamant et diabolisant israélien et
sioniste les résultats du baromètre
montrent que les opinions antisémites
reste largement structuré par des vieux
stéréotypes qui demeurent encore quand
même donc qui qui sont en retrait des
stéréotypes notamment liés à la place
des Juifs dans les médias le rapport à
l'argent ils sont entre guillets de
l'antisémitisme d'extrême droite c'est
ça que vous vlez dire ils sontêt recul
mais il mais il subsiste c'est pas
complètement ça n'a pas disparu d'où
cette nécessité d'une extrême vigilance
et quand effectivement on est dans un
contexte pareil qui une résurgence de
ces actes là on peut pas se contenter de
se dire ça va mieux dans la durée il
faut être extrêmement intolérant à
l'gard de ces actes justement cLID
l'antisémitisme a changé de nature non
l'antisémitisme ça reste la certains
disent je vous pose la question pour
être plus clair certain disur eu un
antisémitis d'extrème droite il est tr
de Tours insupportable non mais je pense
qu'elle fait référence effectivement à
la persistance de clichés
antisémites qui sont diffusés parfois
par des gens sans même s'en rendre
compte et on voit qu'il y a un retour de
l'antisémitisme à la faveur du conflit
israëlo-palestinien ça n'est pas nouveau
ça date notoirement du début des années
2000 après la mort d'raabine et et en
fait l'impasse progressif dans laquelle
dans lequel s'est enfermé ce ce ce
conflit mais l'antisémitisme il est
toujours là et bien présent et pour
beaucoup de Juifs c'est un peu une
tragédie parce qu'ils sont beaucoup sont
découragés et se disent mais ça ne
termine ça ne finira
jamais donc je pense qu'il faut que on
se ressaisisse nous tous on a marché
hier mais il faut que désormais toutes
les forces politiques notamment les
responsables associatifs peu importe
tout le monde sache
identifier ces nouvelles ces nouveaux
signaux d'antisémitisme et lutter contre
résolument parce que l'antisémitisme est
un racisme et nous devons dans notre
pays lutter contre toutes les formes de
racisme c'est insupportable que des gens
soient pris pour cible pour ceux qu'ils
sont voilà tout simplement alors je
voudrais évoquer une absence très
remarquée en tout tout cas très commenté
avec vous Thame celle d'Emmanuel Macron
oui il a brillé par son absence il
n'était pas là et ça a fait plus de
bruit que s'il était venu et d'ailleurs
ça avait commencé bien déjà à la veille
lorsqu'il a dû s'en expliquer Emmanuel
Macron s'expliquer sur les raisons de
son absence de participation il a été
interpellé sur ce sujet par l'arrière
petite fille d'Alfred drefus en marge
des commémorations du 11 novembre
séquence repérée par nos confrères du
hffington post regardez mon rôle est de
prendre des décisions de dire des mots
quand il faut les dur et d'agir sinon je
peux manifester toutes les semaines
c'est vrai c'est vrai vous avez raison
en tous les cas on sait que vous serez
avec nous par le cœur je serai par le
cœur et la pensée j'aurai l'occasion
dans les prochaines heures de lu l
d'accord c'est aussi de l'un pay je
pense que oui je sais c'est compliqué je
comprends merci monsieur le Président
antisémitisme c'est pas comm c'est très
simple ou on ne ConA rien et rien ne jus
merci et je le redirai mais j'ai une
approche qui est à mon avis la seule
dans la République face à not est
universaliste parce que je vois beaucoup
confusion sur le sujet et beaucoup aussi
de
rulur voilà donc défense en trois points
d'une part 1 je ne suis jamais à une à
une manifestation et je veux je ne vais
pas commencer aujourd'hui deuxièmement
mon rôle n'est pas de manifester mais de
bâtir l'unité du pays de dire des mots
c'est ce qu'il a fait ensuite avec sa
lettre au français et d'agir et dernière
phrase il y a beaucoup de confusion et
de récupér tion autour de ce sujet il ne
précise pas vraiment mais on comprend
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a aucune envie de
se mêler des polémiques qui ont précédé
l'organisation de cette marche la
bataille politique il faut le dire elle
a été féroce toute la semaine dernière
on a pu craindre que l'Union citoyenne
recherchée vire à la division totale
entre présence du rassemblement national
et absence de la France insoumise oui il
avait vu le piège pourtant il l'avait
dit devant son discours au Grand Orient
mais ça lui a pas réussi F cette non
déécision voilà là encore et fait
inverse à les fait rechercher puisque
voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui s'engouffre
dans la brèche avec un tweet sur X le
leader de la France insoumise en profite
pour donner son interprétation de la non
participation du président de la
République il y va avec ses gros sabots
voilà ce qu'il écrit Macron a raison
cette soi-disant marche contre
l'antisémitisme à l'appel de meilleur
Habib Le Pen Zemour brun Pivet et
l'arché fonctionne comme une
manipulation comme lui et moi ne vous
laissez pas embobiner rappelons qu'au
contraire Emmanuel Macron a ditque
serait par le cœur et la pensée on vient
de l'entendre mais il est certain qu'il
n'a pas voulu par sa présence cautionner
la présence du rassemblement national ni
avoir en tout cas à s'exprimer sur le
sujet pas plus qu'il ne souhaitait se
mêler des affaires de la France
insoumise et voilà que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en profite donc ironiquement
pour se trouver des points communs avec
le chef de l'État alors au fond il a eu
raison ou pas raison bon la première
chose ce sont les réactions vu que tout
s'est bien passé hier on vient de le
dire les oppositions qui étaient
présentes ne se sont pas privé de
critique on va dire ça c'est le jeu
ensuite vous avez la CRIF vous avez le
CRIF vous avez la Licra qui ont regretté
que seul lui manque à la photo de
l'événement qui aurait été ainsi encore
plus historique c'est plus embêtant ne
manquait qu'Emmanuel Macron à la photo
de famille pour incarner la réponse unie
de la République contre l'antisémitisme
on pense bien sûr à ressusciter l'image
de François am Terran de 1990 après la
profanation du cimetière juif de
Carpentras ou encore celle de François
Hollande défilant en janvier 2015 après
les attentats de Charlie bref il a
manqué une occasion de s'inscrire dans
l'histoire enfin si cette manifestation
reste dans l'histoire n'est-ce pas Jean
garig mais ce qui est le plus embêtant à
mon sens c'est qu'il ne soit pas venu ce
n'est pas qu'il ne soit pas venu c'est
pourquoi il n'est pas venu parce que il
craint des confusions comme il le dit
que cette marche soit vue comme une
marche de soutien à Israël comme les
manifestations proalestiniennes sont
vues comme des manifestations proamas
que l'on importe une fois de plus le
conflit au Proche Orient pour raconter
cette marche française faire cela et
bien c'est essentialiser c'est mettre un
signe égal entre juif et politique
d'Israël entre musulmans Palestiniens et
attaque du Hamas heureusement et bien
finalement ces craintes n'étaient pas
fondées la catastrophe n'a pas eu lieu
et cette marche a finalement été assez
conforme à son projet initial celui d'un
surceaut républicain AP poliitique CIVI
contre ce mal multiséculaire de
l'antisémitisme merci du coup il aurait
pu venir Jean moi je pense qu'il est
tombé dans le piège justement que lui
tendait Jean-Luc Mélenchon de de de cet
amalgame et de de cette crainte
justement de de fracturer encore un peu
plus alors que l'heure est à l'unité ça
là-dessus sur le cap qu'il faut que
notre société à mon sens doit doit
suivre c'est c'est c'est le cap de
l'unité moi au départ j'ai fais partie
de ceux qui étaient un peu choqués qui
ne soit pas venu justement à la
différence de de François mitteran à
carpenta il était pas resté très
longtemps mais il était venu en y
réfléchissant je me dis que si
précisément on est dans un une une
démarche qui doit suivre la marche si
c'est le début de quelque chose alors
peut-être était-il souhaitable que pour
discuter notamment on va pas se le
cacher avec la communauté des musulmans
de France avec les musulmans de France
il était habile de sa part de ne pas
participer à cette à cette marche Paron
peut pas on peut pas être contre
l'antisémitisme et parler avec les
musulmans de France
non mais le problème c'est que je pense
beaucoup le le disent que
vraisemblablement cette marche elle a
été considérée par beaucoup de musulmans
de France comme une forme de soutien à
la politique israélienne c'est faux
c'est totalement faux dans la réalité
mais dans la perception collective et je
pense que il est allé dans dans dans ce
sens Emmanuel Macron sans quoi il a tort
parce qu'il est le président de la
République il incarne l'unité de de la
nation et donc il pouvait très bien être
présent mais il a anticipé un procès qui
aurait pu oui mais c'est pas simple
simplement ça là où j'iraai peut-être
dans son sens mais c'est une hypothèse
c'est que je le répète s'il s'agit
ensuite de lancer quelque chose et
d'élargir par exemple à des initiatives
contre le racisme en général l'exclusion
notamment l'islamophobie mais peut-être
que il il est maintenant dans une
situation meilleure en n'ayant pas
participé à cette à cette marche cl
Ridel Emmanuel Macron explique qu'il n'y
va pas parce qu'il est le garant de
l'unité mais l'unité se forgeit pas dans
le cortège au contraire bah oui je pense
et je je sais pas comment vous mesurez
le fait que les musulmans de France
comme s'il forit un tout pensent que
cette manifestation était une
manifestation de soutien à Israël bah
c'est ce que vous laissez entendre je
trouve que c'est pas bien de laisser
entendre ça parce que la manifestation
d'hier ça n'était pas ça c'était des
manifestation absolument pas dit ça je
vous prierai de ne pas déformer ma
pensée d'abord moi je suis pas là pour
polémiquerés la perception vous avez dit
Monsieur Je
a et je dis que je
mus de c'est ce que vous avez dit j'ai
peur que pour beaucoup de musulmans de
France ils a inter pas dit j'ai peur
vous avez dit je pense mais bon c'est
pas grave je termine mon
propétait pas ça non monsieur je suis
désolé je ne peux pas laisser dire en
plateau que la perception des musulmans
de France serait que la marche pour
l'antisémitisme était une marche à viser
politique de soutien au gouvernement
d'Israël voilà donc il ne faut pas le
laisser entendre et je ne crois pas du
tout que les musulmans de France pens ça
d'ailleurs il y avait certains de leur
représentants à la marche pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup de
représentants du musulmans beaucoup vrai
pas beaucoup c'est vrai mais après voilà
c'est ça vous a surpris surpris non je
je sais pas si j'ai été mis sur
précisément peut-être parce qu'il se
sentait pas à l'aise dans cette marche
bah écoutez je pense qu'il y avait pas
de motif à ce qu'il ne se sentent pas à
l'aise je pense encore une fois que
qu'est-ce qu'ont vu les Français hier
ils ont vu qu'il y avait une grande
marche qui était organisée
pour l' contre l'antisémitisme d'accord
et ils ont regardé qui est une cause
nationale qui est une cause de lutte
contre le racisme point et et ils ont
regardé qui était là et qui n'était pas
là et après on en tire les conclusions
mais je pense que c'était le rôle en
tout cas du plus large nombre de
personnes possibles d'y être justement
voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on a vu les
représentants des des cultes catholiques
par exemple protestants mais pas de
d'officiel on va dire il y avait
certainement
des musulmans dans la manifestation
personne n demandé aux gens quelle était
leur religion s il avait beaucoup de
musulmans cette
manifestation dev y en avoir mais il n'y
avait pas de en tout cas de
représentants des cultes officiels ce
matin ils ont été reçus à l'Élysée les
représentants des cultes par Emmanuel
Macron je vous propose d'écouter Corchia
le président du cons histoire Israélite
de France à la sortie de sa rencontre
avec le président de la République qu'
raconte qui compte maintenant c'est
comment ça va pouvoir se dupliquer sur
le terrain pour qu'au niveau de la
prévention avec nos jeunes pour ce qui
est de la répression aussi des actes
antisémites qui ont eu une flambée on le
sait bien au cours de de ces dernières
semaines comment on va pouvoir
transmettre ça en matière d'acte et je
crois que c'était aussi une des grandes
un des grands apports de cette
discussion qu'on a eu aujourd'hui avec
le avec le président de la République
notamment il l'a dit tout à l'heure par
rapport à nombre de jeunes qui ne
lissent plus nécessairement la presse
qui ne voient même plus rest
particulièrement la télévision ou les
journaux et qui sont parfois enfermés
dans un propre langage et dans une
propre réflexion sans aller vers l'autre
et donc l'objectif du président tel
qu'il nous l'a expliqué tout à l'heure
et que nous aiderons évidemment à
relayer c'est que cette parole puisse
être
diffusée et maintenant comment
transformer l'essai hein c'est la
question qui Tarou de la classe
politique a commencé par les
organisateurs de la marche on a entendu
hier on en parlait sur ce plateau Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat dire
qu'après la marche il fallait une
démarche qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il
entendait par là Tam bah on peut
imaginer hein quand même une une suite
avec un certain nombre de de textes
législatifs on a vu des des groupes qui
sont déjà en train de réfléchir par
exemple sur l'antisémitisme et sa place
sur les réseaux sociaux comment
légiférer contre ça quand on parle de de
la jeunesse et et de la façon dont elle
s'informe aujourd'hui de la place que ça
peut avoir sur les réseaux sociaux bah
voilà qui peut raisonner euh on avait
déjà eu des propositions hein à droite
euh bon qui peuvent être très clivante
hein par exemple sur la criminalisation
de l'antisionisme c'est une proposition
du sénateur Stéphane lerudulier et puis
là on a vu et bien aujourd'hui cette
nouvelle tribune pour le coup plutôt de
sénateur de droite LR qui à nouveau et
bien s'explique sur et bien le les
démarches qu'ils veulent faire contre
l'antisémitisme donc on sent quand même
une traduction parlementaire qui
pourrait être à l'œuvre l'idée c'est de
durcir uneème fois l'arsenal pénal on
rappelle que sur les
1247 signalement he d'acte antisémite
ben il y a eu 539 interpellations la
police vient d'ailleurs d'arrêter été
aujourd'hui les jeunes vous savez qu'on
avait vu dans le métro anentoné des
slogans ou des champs antisémites qui
avaient beaucoup circulé sur les résaux
sociaux l'opinion elle est demandeuse
d'une façon générale d'un de plus de
sévérité de d'un durcissement alors sur
ce sujet là en particulier je voudrais
pas m'avancer il y a pas une mesure
récente mais de manière générale on sent
effectivement un peu un mouvement de
fond de une demande d'autorité de
fermeté et de je voudrais pas presque
aller jusqu'au à dire d'ordre mais c'est
quelque choseordre l'ordre l'ordre avait
dit Emmanuel Macron après les é mon lie
c'est on sent quand même que cette
rentrée elle se fait quand même sur le
signe d'une demande de ex effectiv
d'autorité de part publicè ouais c'est
c'est très clair Jean euh les le
président de la République a invité les
représentants des cultes à multiplier
les actions éducatives donc probablement
l'école l'éducation aussi son rle à
jouer mais au fond est-ce que c'est le
boulot des profs est-ce que c'est pas
encore autre chose qu'on va leur
demander c'est vrai que moi je pense
fondamentalement que la plupart des des
des enseignants de ce pays ils font ce
travail ils le font je connais beaucoup
de gens qui sont dans le primaire le
secondaire le à l'université on est tout
le temps en train de de travailler
là-dessus rapper ce que sont les
principes républicains l'antisémitisme
l'islamophobie et cetera
euh demander ça aux enseignants pourquoi
pas il y a beaucoup d'efforts qui sont
faits de plus en plus mais ça ne suffira
pas il faut que le reste de la société
s'y mette les associations les les élus
locaux et cetera l'état bien sûr c'est
pourquoi je dis moi que les médias les
médias beaucoup les médias parce que on
sait bien qu'il y a des médias qui euh
au contraire travaille à à mettre de
l'huile sur le feu à enflammer la les
choses et que dans ces médias là on n
pas beaucoup on n'est pas prêt
finalement à la à la démarche dont je
parlais puisque moi ma démarche pour
expliquer cette dame qui a peut-être pas
tout à fait compris ce que je voulais
dire elle elle doit elle doit s'élargir
elle doit mais non très bien compris ce
que vou dire ne revenez pas vers moi
j'ai très bien compris ce que V p
parumente je veux dire c'est que
précisément cette démarche d'unité doit
pas se cantonner à l'antisémitisme et
doit s'élargir y compris au racisme
antimusulman c'est ça qui est très
important ou antiarab tout ce que vous
voudrez de nombreuses personnes hier
étaient à cette manifestation d'ailleurs
plus par racisme antimusulman notamment
l'extrême droite de Monsieur Zemour et
et Marine Le Pen plutôt que pour de
réelles convictions contre
l'antisémitisme puisque il y a 5 jours
pas plus tard qu'il y a 5 jours monsieur
Bardella a était incapable de qualifier
monsieur Jean-Marie Le Pen d'antisémite
donc alors on va venir justement est-ce
que on a assisté hier avec cette marche
inédite à une forme de recomposition
politique avec la présence de nombreux
représentants de l'extrême droite on va
en parler avec Steve Jourdain que
j'invite à rentrer sur sur ce
plateau Steve bonsoir bonsoir alors le
rassemblement national était à la marche
contre l'antisémitisme c'est vrai que
comme ça ça paraît assez surprenant
cétait en tout cas inédit totalement
inédit c'est la première fois que le
parti est accepté à une manifest station
républicaine on va faire un petit
flashback autre contexte en 2015 on s'en
souvient après l'attentat de Charlie
plusieurs partis de gauche sont à
l'initiative d'une grande marche à Paris
entre la Place de la République et la
nation manuel Vals est alors Premier
ministre il convie l'UMP et Nicolas
Sarkozi pour y participer mais quand on
lui demande si le RN doit en être il est
alors beaucoup beaucoup moins clair on
va l'écouter chacun doit être marqué
uniquement par ce seul objectif l'unité
nationale au-delà des partis au-delà des
opinionstion il ne peut pas y avoir
d'exclusiontional est associé mais la
réponse que nous devons la réponse
jean-michelti moi dans ce moment-là je
fais pas de la politique au sens
classique du terme mais l'unité
nationale c'est aussi autour de valeurs
de valeurs profondément républicaine de
tolérance de refus d'amalgame voilà
finalement le RN ne sera pas en à la
marche Marine Le Pen la un peu mauvaise
on va voir ce qu'elle écrit alors sur
Twitter nous allons les laisser entre
eux nous serons au côté du peuple
français le RN et ses militants
défileront finalement mais à beauer
petit fière du parti qui se situe dans
le gare loin très loin de la manif
monstre qui est alors organisé à Paris
et bien une nouvelle tentative 3 ans
après d'intégrer les rang de la
République à travers la manifestation en
hommage à Mireille knnol on sen souvient
marche blancheilà marche blanche
organisé en mars 2018 quelques jours
plus tôt effectivement une femme juive
de 85 ans rescapé de la Choa a été tuée
poignardée à son domicile une
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme est
prévue à Paris à l'App à l'appel du
Conseil représentatif des Juifs de
France tout le monde est convviés tous
non sauf Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le
Pen ils sont jugés indésira par le CRIF
Mélenchon en raison de ses positions à
l'égard d'Israël Marine Le Pen du fait
du passif de son parti mais elle y va
quand même et elle est reçu comme ça
regardez autrich en Autriche avec les
espèce de merde en Autriche avec
les en
Autriche
danser et puis elle s'est rendue donc à
la marge d'hier elle a finalement été
assez peu chahuté c'est une nouvelle
étape vers la normalisation une étape
supplémentaire c'est ce qu'on pense en
tout cas à l'intérieur au sein du parti
depuis plusieurs années on essae de
gommer le passé antisémite à l'intérieur
du du rassemblement national Louis Aliot
vice-président du RN et ancien directeur
de du cabinet d'un certain Jean-Marie Le
Pen a déclaré par le passé la chose
suivante la dédiabolisation ne porte que
sur l'antisémitisme en distribuant des
traacs dans la rue le seul plafond de
verre que je voyez ce n'était pas
l'immigration ce n'était pas l'islam
d'autres sont PIR que nous sur ces
sujets là c'est l'antisémitisme qui
empêche les gens de voter pour nous il
n'y a que cela à partir du moment où
vous faites sauter ce verrou idéologique
vous libérez le reste le reste c'est
quoi c'est l'accession au pouvoir on en
est encore loin Mathieu mais la
participation du RN à la marche
républicaine hier est un moment
important dans l'histoire du parti et
peut-être dans l'histoire de notre
République je venir nous le dire merci
Steve Jean garig on a assisté à un
moment de bascule hier avec la présence
de l'extrême droite dans ce cortège
républicain disons en tout cas que que
ça s'inscrit dans ce processus
d'installation de dédiabolisation
normalisation du du du rassemblement
national en historien je suis obligé de
constater que le rassemblement national
de Marine Le Pen c'est pas le Front
national de Jean-Marie Le Pen que dans
le discours officiel ils ont rompu avec
les provocations antisémites de du papa
bon on sait que y compris dans
l'entourage de Marine Le Pen les la
communication de Marine Le Pen il y a
des gens qui ont été très proches des
idées antisémites du Gude et cetera qui
a une histoire antisémite de l'extrême
droite tout ça est vrai mais on est
obligé de constater que là ils ont
marqué un point en participant à cette à
cette manifestation à cette marche
pardon à cette marche ils ont marqué un
point euh maintenant je pense que les
les gens enfin je l'espère en tout cas
il nous appartient il appartient à ceux
qui observent la vie politique de de
rappeler ce que d'où vient le
rassemblement national ce que ce que
sont leur leurs idées mais c'est vrai
aujourd'hui qu'au fond le rassemblement
national se se focalise beaucoup plus
sur l'europhobie et forme de d'Islam
hobie qui passe par l'immigration que
que sur l'antisémitisme c'est c'est plus
leur cheval de de bataille mais il reste
quand même un vieux fond et et ce vieux
fond là en les intégrant à cetteif enfin
en les intégrant pas tout à fait en
autorisant qu'il qu'il participe à cette
manifestation à cette marche je le
répète bah voilà ils se sont un petit
peu ils ont franchi un un pas de plus
vers la la
notabilité de zulficarpic ils ont on
marqué le point pour reprendre
l'expression de de jean- Garic dans
l'opinion je me pose la question je
pense qu' effectivement ça s'inscrit
dans ce mouvement dans la durée de
normalisation de diabolisation est-ce
que effectivement hier il s'est passé
quelque chose après ils étaient pas en
tête du cortège avec l'ensemble des des
représentants nationaux ils était dans
rappelle qu'il y avait pas de
représentants de parti hein sous la de
tête c'était les corps constitués les
officiels mais il y avait pas de
représentant de parti en tant que tel
non non mais effectivement ils étaient
quand même un peu en que de cortège
plutôt entre eux donc je sais pas est-ce
qu'il va rester dans l'opinion public
euh en revanche c'est vrai que c'est
c'est en tout cas une rupture indéniable
avec avec l'époque où le Front
républicain prévalait c'est enfin voilà
il s'est vraiment produit quelque chose
après Jean garig évoquait ce vieux fond
la question que je me pose moi c'est
est-ce que c'est ce vieux fond de
d'antisémitisme et qui qui enfin qui et
on voit d'ailleurs dans l'opinion
publique l'image du RN a évolué alors ça
ça reste un parti qui est jugé xénophobe
pour un Français sur deux mais ça veut
quand même dire que pour un Français sur
deux il ne l'est plus donc voilà ce sont
des chiffres que je un peu comme ça et
dans un sondage dans l'institut
concurrent du vôre paru vendredi dans Le
Figaro euh enquê au doxa pas la nommeré
54 % des Français interrogés jugeaent la
participation du RN à cette
manifestation illégitime illégitime ok
mais ve dire voilà et voilà et tout
comme sur sur l'item est-ce que c'est un
parti qui vous inquiète qui est
dangereux pour la démocratie on est sur
un rapport de 1/ de mais moi ce que la
question que je voulais poser c'est en
fait est-ce que finalement c'est ça le
vrai sujet parce que pour autant même si
effectivement on sent ce ce ce vieux
fondeux et cetera est-ce que c'est un
frein suffisant pour empêcher
l'accession du RN au notamment à des
fonctions présidentielles j'en veux pour
preuve un autre chiffre que vous cez mes
concurrents je je m'en prive pas dans la
dernière enquête fracture française on a
cet syème qui est posé pour tous les
partis est-ce que vous Dirz que ce parti
est capable de gouverner le RN se classe
en 2uxè position derrière les
républicains avec près d'un Français sur
deux qui considère qu'il est capable de
gouverner donc est-ce qu'il y a en voilà
je suis pas sûr et ça c'est nouveau il
surpasse pardon le Parti socialiste les
écologistes et je ne parle même pas de
LFI on en viiendra peut-être après mais
voilà est-ce que est-ce que le plafond
de verre a été effectivement passé
est-ce que c'est voilà est-ce que mais
il est clair en tout cas que je sais pas
s'il marque le point cette fois là mais
en tout cas dans la durée il se passe
vraiment quelque chose CLA Ridel le RN
dans la manif c'est le signe d'une
grande confusion c'est le signe d'une
évolution du rassemblement national ou
c'est un coup médiatique ou politique je
je crois pas que ce soit le signe d'une
évolution il a elbron pivé et Monsieur
Larcher ont demandé que le RN ne
participe pas à cette marche le CRIF a
demandé au Ren de ne pas participer à
cette marche donc on va dire que les
organisateurs officiel de cette marque
ont rejeté la participation du Ren et
nous force politique de gauche nous
l'avons aussi
vigoureusement rejeté nous n'avons
jamais cautionné que le RN participe à
cette marche pour autant nous nous avons
décidé contrairement à la France
insoumise d'y aller parce que c'était
notre place d'être à cette marche ce
n'était pas à nous de partir et je
préfère des collectifs par exemple de
juifes et de juif juif de gauche comme
le collectif golem qui se se serait
senti bien seul si nous n'étions pas
venus les soutenir et qui sont allés à
la marche en manifestant contre la
présence du rassemblement national à
cette marche mais en réalité 5 jour
avant par antisémite pour vous c'est un
parti qui est qui est l'héritier d'un
parti qui a été antisém en fait si vous
voulez euh les choses se sont clarifiées
dimanche dernier quand Jordane Bardella
a refusé de qualifier Jean-Marie Le Pen
d'antisémite alors même que ce
personnage a été condamné non mais c'est
pas je ne le crois pas
c'est je vous répond Monsieur Le Pen a
été condamné à plusieurs reprises pour
antisémitisme donc quand on n'est pas
capable de dire qu'un chat est un chat
ça pose question si vous voulez sur la
sincérité du combat derrière contre
l'antisémitisme donc je pense plutôt que
ça relève d'un coup que que d'un vrai
changement politique je n'y crois pas du
tout je pense que ça reste du R inage de
façade tant qu'ils ne sont pas capables
de regarder leur histoire en face et
d'en tirer les conséquences c'est qu'en
gros il peut pas continuer comme ça à
tenter de faire obouer leur passer par
petite touche sans faire un véritable
agjournamento je je franchement là je je
je suis c'est très difficile à dire on
voit bien les historiens qui travaillent
sur le sur le le rassemblement national
sont sont là-dessus circonspect on ne
peut que rappeler ce ce leurs origines
et je le répète enquêter très
sérieusement sur des qui existe encore
entre Marine Le Pen et des des gens qui
ont proféré des idées antisémites ou des
partis étrangers avec lesquels a pu
avoir des liens et qui étit inspiré par
l'antisémitisme voilà des des choses
concrètes pour le reste après c'est
c'est est-ce que vous avez raison de le
dire est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
est suffisamment dissuasif pour en tout
cas pour les l'électorat de base du du
rassemblement national ça j'en suis pas
sûr mais moi je suis quand même frappée
par certaines prises de de parole
notamment bien cheer qui disent
maintenant et bien on peut considérer le
rassemblement national comme un parti
républicain et et qui y intègre et qui
sortent vraiment la France insoumise à
la faveur de cette de cette marche mais
même auparavant donc peut-être je sais
pas si les Français vont aussi vite que
euh la droite de l'hémicycle mais je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même
très très clair et déjà depuis plusieurs
jours louisot et que nous racontait
Steve jourain
dernier verrou c'était C voilà et le
verrou il a sauté sans doute ensuite
pour pouvoir aller vers des accords avec
avec la droite le RN on voit enfin c'est
quand même ça a beaucoup évolué avec
accordvez positionn ou les positionn du
rassemblement national program qui se
ressembl comme de gouttes d'eau je
voudrais qu'on consacre les dernières C
dernière minutes de cette émission a
évoqué le cas d'un d'un autre absent de
la manifestation évidemment Jean Luc
Mélenchon qui du début à la fin aura
tenté de de de perturber ou de polluer
l'organisation de cette manifestation
dont il voyait au tout début le
rendez-vous des soutiens inconditionnels
du massacre comme si cette manifestation
cette marge hierère était une marche de
soutien à Benjamin netaniaou ce qui
était pas le cas et puis qui a fini hier
soir en en disant que c'était le
rassemblement de la droite et de
l'extrême droite un rassemblement
rabougri euh il est sorti des railes j
MCH pour vous clidel bah moi je l'ai dit
je regrette l'absence de la France
insoumise à cette marche parce que les
Français voient quoi voi qu'il y a une
grande marche contre l'antisémitisme qui
est organisé dans notre pays que tous
les partis politiques participent sauf
un des plus enfin le plus ant parti
politique de la gauche donc ils ont
manifesté contre l'antisémitisme
ailleurs mais pas dans ils ont organisé
une commémoration de la nu cristal puis
une coration des victimes du de la r du
ils ont ils se sont ils se sont
mobilisés mais il fallait être à cette
marche ça n'était pas à nous de partir
de cette marche euh c'était au RN d'en
partir il fallait que nous soyons
présent et beaucoup de Juifs
l'attendaient donc je pense que c'est
une erreur je pense que c'est une erreur
de ne pas y avoir été et qui vient après
un mois de prise de position qu'on quand
même créé les mois ou sinon le trouble y
compris dans la gauche he que ce soit le
le refus de initial de qualifier
d'attaque terroriste les les attaques du
Hamas que ce soit le parallèle avec la
résistance qui a été faite par par une
députée madame
auonau le Parti socialiste peut encore
s'allier électoralement avec la France
insoumise après depuis 7 octobre mais en
réalité enfin c'est pas nous vous savez
que nous avons décidé de d'une pause
d'un moratoire dans l'inou dire qu'on
peut reprendre l'alliance dans
l'intergroupe de l'anups non mais
l'anupes c'est un intergroupe à
l'Assemblée nationale hein c'est pas
autre chose chacun a sa formation
politique donc aujourd'hui cet
intergroupe ne fonctionne plus comme
avant puisque nous avons demandé à ce
qu'il y ait des disc tion pour clarifier
un certain nombre de positions sur le
fond et puis surtout pour clarifier une
méthode parce qu'effectivement il faut
qu'on puisse prendre des positions en en
en ayant discuté ensemble et pas en se
laissant prendre en otage par les
positions des uns et des autres et en
affichant du coup nos divergences sur
l'espace public comme ça a été le cas
parce que clarifier les positions pour
le coup les positions es sont assez
claires cell qu'on exprimé la France
insoumise depuis les massacres du 7
octobre Adé de zouf plque ça lui coûte
dans l'opinion à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
plus largement la France insoumise alors
ça ça coûte dans l'opinion al c'est
difficile de dissocier la franche
insoumiss de son leader pour l'instant
ce qui est très clair mais c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau ça fait
maintenant quelques quelques mois il y a
eu aussi plein de
dysfonctionnement par le passé que on
voit globalement la France insoumise
pastir du de de enfin de ce que fait son
leader et on le voit je vous disais tout
à l'heure je vous donnais quelques
chiffres qui concerernent le RN en fait
aujourd'hui la France insumist fait plus
peur aux Français que le assemblement
national à la question de savoir si
c'est un parti dangereux pour la
démocratie on a 52 % pour le RN à 57 %
pour la France insoumise et sur toute
une série d'itè justement de quand on
regarde la crédibilité des différents
partis c'est la France insoumise qui est
aujourd'hui en France est perçu comme le
parti le moins crédible le plus
dangereux pour la démocratie et cetera
et cetera et on voit aussi que au sein
des différents différentes personnalités
de la France insoumise il y en a qui
émergent plutôt positivement je pense à
Clémentine Autin je pense à François
Ruffin clairement Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
aujourd'hui perçu par les Français et y
compris par une partie des électeurs de
gauche de plus en plus comme un ap pour
son camp plus que comme un atout Jean
rapidement et pour conclure est-ce qu'il
est sorti de l'arc républicain c'est une
formule qu'on entend beaucoup où est-ce
qu'il est sorti de la gauche ou de la
gauche de gouvernement moi je il est
sorti de la gauche de gouvernement à
coup sûr et d'ailleurs on voit très bien
que se dessine une autre ligne au sein
même de la de la France insoumise et que
des des relations des des des réunions
ont lieu entre certains dirigeants de la
France insoumise François Ruffin en tête
certains élus ont manifesté d'ailleurs à
Strasbourg él exactement qui ont
manifesté à Strasbourg avec des
écologistes des communistes des
socialistes peut-être je sais pas et euh
non non je ne dirais pas qu'il est sorti
de l'arc républicain il y a pas de
raison de lui faire ce ce ce GEF ils
n'ont pas participé à cette réunion à
cette marche ils ont eu tort parce que
c'était une marche d'unité républicaine
précisément ils ont eu et extrêmement
tort non c'est je il faut pas renvoyer
les des signes d'égalité entre ce qu'est
l'histoire et le vécu de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce qui est le le rassemblement
national simplement je trouve que cette
stratégie de conflictualité common sait
déjà à l'Assemblée elle est à mon sens
elle le transforme une sorte d'idiot
utile de rassemblement national parce
que qu'est-ce qui se passe on voit que
sa côte chute dans les dans les sondages
qu'on ne lui fait plus confiance alors
que de l'autre côté tranquillement le
rassemblement national tisse sa toile
donc quelque part là il y a une sorte de
voilà d'équilibre qui est qui est qui
est rompu et et qui est néfaste
notamment à ce que beaucoup de gens
attendent c'est-à-dire une une nouvelle
gauche qui puisse proposer quelque chose
d'alternatif à à ce qu'on nous Pr
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci à tous les trois d'y avoir
participé